was tun gegen die wirtschaftskrise in
europa deutschland und frankreich
einigen sich auf einen 500 milliarden
euro schweren wiederaufbauplan was ist
mit dem nächsten sommerurlaub
deutschland wird die generelle weltweite
reisewarnung wohl mitte juni aufheben
und was für ein künstler michel piccoli
der großen charakterdarsteller stirbt im
alter von 94 jahren
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend seien sie
willkommen hier das wichtigste vom tage
um 19 uhr
und da steht eine gewaltige summe am
beginn dieser sendung 500 milliarden
euro als wiederaufbauhilfe für die eu
länder die von der carola krise stark
gebeutelt wurden auf diesen vorschlag
haben sich bundeskanzlerin merkel und
der französische präsident makro heute
nachmittag geeinigt es sind keine corona
bonds darauf wird wert gelegt das geld
fließt aus dem eu-haushalt florian
neumann berichtet ohne dünger verkümmert
vieles das gilt für die rasenfläche vor
dem kanzleramt und das gilt für die
vermeintlich größte freundschaft zweier
nationen um die sie sich heute hier
drinnen kümmern videokonferenz- zwischen
angela merkel und emanuel makro nachdem
es in der krise wegen deutscher
grenzschließungen französischen unmut
gegeben hatte heute ein gemeinsamer
neustart
ich glaube wenn deutschland und
frankreich einen impuls geben ist das
etwas was die meinungsfindung in europa
befördert wir müssen europäisch handeln
damit wir gut aus dieser krise
herauskommen
dafür schlagen merkel und makro eine
gemeinsame antwort vor einem eu
wiederaufbau vor in höhe von 500
milliarden euro erstmals soll die eu
dafür eigene kredite aufnehmen dürfen
verteilt werden soll das geld dann aus
dem eu haushalt nicht als kredit sondern
als gezielte förderung für stark
betroffene staaten
damit werden jene unterstützt die einen
größeren bedarf haben ich glaube das ist
ein ganz grundlegender wandel und das
ist was die europäische union in dieser
krise braucht um ihre einheit zu wahren
es wäre ein historischer schritt sagen
europa experten aber bislang ist es nur
eine idee
das ist ein gutes zeichen dass
deutschland und frankreich das erste mal
in dieser krise an einem strang ziehen
und gemeinsam bereit sind ein vorschlag
vorzulegen der die probleme dieser krise
wirklich an angeht aber natürlich ist
das nicht ausreichend denn wir brauchen
auch die zustimmung der anderen
mitgliedstaaten um die werden beide
jetzt intensiv werben müssen zb bei der
bislang sehr zurückhaltenden regierung
der niederlande 500 milliarden in form
von zu
schüssen nicht darlehen das ist schon
eine größenordnung fragen an unsere
korrespondenten in paris und berlin
zuerst theo koll in berlin da hat sich
deutschland ja offenkundig ein gutes
stück auf seine kritiker in der eu zu
bewegte oder ja wobei bewegt haben sich
beide seiten die kanzlerin nannte das
eben man habe sich zusammengerauft die
bundesregierung ist zwar einerseits
bereit viel zusätzliches geld für corona
geschädigte bereiche und regionen zu
zahlen aber sie hält andererseits an
wesentlichen prinzipien fest das heißt
es gibt keine corona bonds keine
vergemeinschaftung von schulden was es
geben soll sind zusätzliche 500
milliarden die von europa als kredit
aufgenommen werden dürfen und an
krisenstaaten als zuschüsse ausgezahlt
werden das ist ein klares deutsches
zugeständnis der kredit soll dann
anteilig von den mitgliedsländern
abbezahlt werden
für deutschland heißt das rund 135
milliarden die langfristig und über den
eu-haushalt abzubezahlen sind also ein
klassischer kompromiss
thomas walde in paris damit scheint die
deutsch-französische lokomotive wie es
immer so schön heißt ja wieder flossen
sein was bedeutet das für makro mann
hatte während der gesamten krise stets
ein gemeinsames europäisches vorgehen
gefordert und massive öffentliche hilfen
beidem ist heute ein ganzes stück näher
gekommen
auch wenn er sich mit seiner forderung
nach eurobonds nachdem ein selber
verschuldung offensichtlich nicht
durchgesetzt hat aber wichtig für ihn
ist dass er hier etwas vorweisen kann
denn innenpolitisch gerät gerade schwer
unter druck das gesundheitswesen kommt
mit der krise mehr schlecht als recht
zurande
die wirtschaftsleistung bricht gerade
massiv ein das kurzarbeitergeld soll
demnächst gekürzt werden alle seine
innenpolitischen reformen liegen auf eis
und seine regierungsmehrheit im
parlament die schwindet gerade da hilft
es ihm wenn er sich zumindest auf
europäischer ebene als jemand
präsentieren kann der initiativen
gemeinsam mit deutschland voranbringen
vielen dank thomas und vielen dank theo
nach paris und berlin
und auch dies eine wichtige nachricht
für die bundesbürger
die heutige entscheidung in sachen
sommerurlaub der kann im prinzip
stattfinden auch im ausland das hat
außenminister maß heute klar gemacht
nachdem er sich mit seinen amtskollegen
aus zehn der in deutschland beliebtesten
reiseländer abgestimmt hat denn die
weltweite reisewarnung wird die
bundesregierung voraussichtlich aufheben
und zwar ab dem 15 juni und von land zu
land in reisehinweise umwandeln deutsche
könnten dann vielleicht wieder an
spanische strände oder in die
österreichischen berge zu früh sagt
bayerns ministerpräsident söder
stattdessen sollten anreize her in
deutschland urlaub zu machen
david sauer berichtet sommer sonne
strand hier auf mallorca gibt es das
alles dieser tage aber mit weniger
deutschen touristen als üblich und auch
in nizza lockt das mittelmeer zum bade
und die promenade des anglais ist
herausgeputzt
wären da nicht die reisebeschränkungen
die urlaub in europa derzeit schwer bis
unmöglich machen
um das zu ändern hat außenminister maß
mit kollegen aus zehn europäischen
ländern gesprochen
wir wollen kein europäisches wettbieten
um touristen sondern wir wollen ein
abgestimmtes und transparentes vorgehen
wir hoffen dass wir am 15 juni in der
lage sein werden die generelle weise
reisewarnung die wir haben zu ersetzen
durch reisehinweise aus dem für jeden
hervorgeht wo man hin reisen kann was
einen dort erwartet die absicht zu
öffnen haben viele länder erklärt
konkrete zeitpunkt aber nur wenige und
es bleibt klärungsbedarf was wenn eine
zweite infektionswelle kommt wenn wieder
quarantäne droht oder menschen im
ausland strand rückholaktionen soll es
schließlich keine mehr geben
die deutsch-österreichische grenze ist
ab dem 15 juni wieder geöffnet
am nachmittag macht sich ein seltenes
paar dort gemeinsam ein bild
bundesinnenminister seehofer und bayerns
ministerpräsident söder
die csu will urlaub in deutschland nun
gezielt fördern
wir sollten ein anreiz dafür setzen dass
kann steuerlich sein das kann direkt
sein dass das geld auch ausgegeben wird
und danach am besten im eigenen land
das würde zb ihnen helfen wie in bayern
warten bundesweit hotels darauf endlich
voll in die saison starten zu können
in vielen deutschen regionen von den
alpen bis an die küsten ist der
tourismus nämlich wichtiger
wirtschaftsfaktor und der liegt seit
wochen brach in schleswig-holstein läuft
der ferienbetrieb seit heute wieder an
vor den fähren und zügen nach süd gab es
prompt lange schlangen ab wann wo und
wie kann sommerurlaub möglich sein
online in der zdf- heute- app haben
wieder informationen für sie
zusammengestellt etwa wie sich die
urlaubsländer auf mögliche öffnungen
vorbereiten
aufräumen und durchgreifend
arbeitsminister heil wählte drastische
worte angesichts der missstände in der
fleischindustrie nach nordrhein
westfalen verzeichnet nun auch
niedersachsen einen massiven corona
ausbruch in einem schlachthof die
ursachen bowl mangelnde hygiene und
verstöße gegen die abstandsregeln auf
neue regeln für die branche konnte sich
das corona kabinett aber heute noch
nicht einigen
heike slansky aus berlin eine
sammelunterkunft für billiglöhne aus
osteuropa um die sich fahrer kosten seit
acht jahren kümmert menschen
zusammengepfercht auf engstem raum die
in deutschlands schlachthöfen schuften
jetzt müssen sie auch noch in quarantäne
wegen krone wenn wir uns vorstellen dass
dort auch kindergartenkinder und
schulkinder bohren dann mögen wir uns
das gar nicht so wirklich vorstellen
also es sind einfachste standards man
kann sieht man es auch von außen und die
menschen hausen dort und zahlen eine
woche miete dafür wieder einen
schlachtbetrieb mit corona fällen wieder
die firma westfleisch wieder
subunternehmen inakzeptable arbeits und
lebensbedingungen dagegen will
bundesarbeitsminister hey jetzt vorgehen
macht öffentlichen druck denn im
kabinett gibt es noch gesprächsbedarf
aus den reihen der csu leben das mit
hoher energie konstruktion von sub sub
sub unternehmer ich kann noch einen sub
dranhängen kreiert werden um löhne zu
drücken sozialschutz und auch
gesundheitsschutz zu umgehen
billigfleisch hygienevorschriften
mindestlohn keine neuen erkenntnisse
doch
wegschauen geht nicht mehr die korona
krise zwingt zum handeln
die opposition drängelt deutschland ist
ja europaweit als billiglohnland
verschrien
daran muss sich dringend etwas ändern
denn den hohen preis für das billige
fleisch seien arbeiter in den schlacht
fabriken jeder beschäftigte sollte einen
anspruch auf ein einzelzimmer mit
eigenen sanitären anlagen haben das muss
durchgesetzt werden proteste vor dem
kanzleramt heute billigfleisch und
menschenunwürdige zustände am mittwoch
erneut auf der tagesordnung im kabinett
die zahl der neuinfektionen in
deutschland bleibt auf einem
vergleichsweise niedrigen niveau
im durchschnitt der vergangenen woche
steckten sich 640 menschen pro tag mit
dem corona virus an
insgesamt sind mehr als 176.000
infektionen durch tests bestätigt rund
155000 erkrankte gelten als genesen 7
1988 menschen starben in verbindung mit
cupid 19
solange die ansteckungszahlen niedrig
bleiben können die lockerungen in den
verschiedenen lebensbereichen
weitergehen in einigen bundesländern
haben heute wieder schulen und auch
kitas geöffnet für den eingeschränkten
regelbetrieb viele eltern dürften diesen
tag herbeigesehnt haben
und doch sind auch skeptische stimmen zu
hören wie thomas bärsch sachsen
berichtet die eltern müssen abstand
halten und dürfen nicht mit rein alltag
im sogenannten eingeschränkten
regelbetrieb sachsen öffnet kitas und
grundschulen unter strengen hygiene
regeln feste gruppen und abstandhalten
auch bei den kleinsten
doch gerade in kitas mit offenen
konzepten stößt das auf kritik der ganze
alltag ist durchzogen eigentlich von
maßregelungen die sehr stark in das
pädagogische konzept eingreifen wo wir
dann sagen dass das können wir so nicht
umsetzen zwei lange monate der zuhause
betreuung gehen heute zu ende
die eltern die ihre kinder hier in
dresden zur schule bringen zeigen sich
schon etwas erleichtert doch ein rest
skepsis bleibt froh dass es wieder
losgehen kann also auf der einen seite
und dann natürlich ja mal gucken wie es
alles so an läuft also es macht mir ein
bisschen sorgen andererseits wenn ich
mir halt die fallzahlen angucken die wir
momentan interessen haben sind sie ja
sehr nett rechner dann versucht man sich
halt so selber zu beruhigen und um mal
schon wie es sich weiterentwickelt
sachsen hat seinen vorstoß in ein
regelwerk gegossen schulklassen sollen
zeitversetzt kommen und unter sich
bleiben auch in den pausen zwecks
kontakt vermeidung die gewerkschaft gew
zeigt sich nicht überzeugt gerade wegen
der älteren fachkräfte in schulen und
kitas also als erstes waren ganz viele
erschrocken ganz viele sind besorgt um
ihre eigene gesundheit mit dieser
weitreichenden öffnung waren natürlich
automatisch auch verbunden dass der
schutz von beschäftigten aufgegeben
worden ist es sind fragen offen der buch
kindergarten in leipzig hat für sich
eine lösung gefunden und leicht mit
zelten auf die leipziger rennbahn aus
erschafft platz um für kinder und
personal viel vom kita feeling aus der
vor corinna zeit zu erhalten
diese entscheidung aus potsdam macht die
zerrissenheit der afd deutlich andreas
kalbitz bleibt mitglied der
landtagsfraktion in brandenburg und das
obwohl er vor drei tagen noch aus der
bundes partei geflogen ist wegen seiner
kontakte ins rechtsextreme milieu
neben jan hoet gilt kalbitz als
wichtigster vertreter des formal
aufgelösten rechtsnationalen flügels der
partei
jan meyer aus potsdam die afg fraktion
demonstrierte geschlossenheit
18 von 21 abgeordneten stimmten für die
änderung ihrer geschäftsordnung kallwitz
bleibt auch als parteiloser einer von
ihnen
ich bin also wieder mitglied der
fraktion
die frage des vorsitzes habe ich
ausgelassen bis zu dem zeitpunkt wo der
rechtliche klärung erfolgt ist
am freitag hatte der bundesvorstand kfd
mitgliedschaft für nichtig erklärt wegen
kontakten ins recht
doch gibt er sich sicher dass die
brandenburger parteifreunde ihre meinung
doch noch ändern
die brandenburgische landtagsfraktionen
hat entschieden dass sie abwarten will
bis die entscheidung rechtlichen bestand
hat das kann nicht nachvollziehen
der bundesvorstand ist überzeugt diese
entscheidung wird rechtlichen bestand
haben und im lichte dieser entscheidung
werden die kollegen in brandenburg dann
neu entscheiden
der rückhalt für den rechtsaußen
kallwitz ist groß besonders im osten bei
den landtagswahlen in brandenburg holte
er über 23 prozent der stimmen
sein rauswurf aus der partei stellt die
afg vor eine zerreißprobe
es gibt hier gegenläufige fliehkräfte
teilweise ein teil der partei der im
bürgerlich respekt abeln zumindest im
erscheinungsbild nach bleiben will
also auch eine verfassungsschutz
beobachtung vermeiden will und teile die
eigentlich im grunde genommen eine
größere und erfolgreichere npd wollen
auch sein amt als brandenburger
parteichef hat kalbes verloren doch sein
landesverband fordert nun einen
sonderparteitag zur abwahl des
bundesvorstandes
lange wurde gestritten wie es mit dem
ausbau der öko-energie weitergeht jetzt
hat sich die koalition geeinigt
ein streitpunkt war die frage wieweit
windkraftanlagen von wohnhäusern
entfernt sein müssen
1000 meter stehen im gesetz aber die
bundesländer dürfen davon jetzt mit
eigenen regelungen abweichen
und auch der ausbau bei solarenergie
kann weiter gehen die grenze bis zu der
gefördert wird fällt weg sie wäre bald
erreicht gewesen
das was jetzt erreicht worden ist stellt
sicher dass der ausbau der energiewende
und der das umsetzen unserer
klimapolitischen ziele weiterhin im
konsens geschieht im konsens mit den
bürgerinnen und bürgern dieses landes
aber auch im konsens mit den großen
beiden großen regierungsfraktionen sagte
der bundeswirtschaftsminister
anderes thema selten stand die
weltgesundheitsorganisation whu derart
im fokus und selten war sie so
umstritten
ihr hauptziel
alle völker sollen so gesund wie möglich
sein konkret überwacht die bhu globale
entwicklungen etwa bei solchen sie
schätzt die gefahren ein und ruft im
schlimmsten fall den gesundheitsnotstand
aus bei corona war das ende januar
die usa kritisieren nun das war viel zu
spät es gibt also einiges zu besprechen
ab heute auf der whu jahresversammlung
an abbas berg wie gemeinsam gegen korona
kämpfen darum soll es bei der whu
hauptversammlung in genf gehen online
mit videobotschaften aus den 194
mitgliedsländern
diese krise kann kein land allein lösen
wir müssen gemeinsam handeln die
weltgesundheitsorganisation ist die
legitimierte globale institution bei der
die fäden zusammenlaufen merkel stärkt
der whu den rücken in einer zeit in der
andere die un-sonderorganisation heftig
kritisieren vor allem trump warf ihr
missmanagement während der korona
pandemie vor und wollte die
beitragszahlungen stoppen
als bisher grösster geldgeber es geht
viel weniger darum jetzt gemeinsam die
pandemie einzudämmen sondern eher um die
austragung das schlecht auch die
autorität der organisation die gerade
jetzt wichtige aufgaben zu erfüllen hat
die gerechte verteilung des corona
impfstoffs zum beispiel wenn es ihn dann
gibt gleichzeitig ist die whu chronisch
unterfinanziert gerade mal rund 20
prozent ihres budgets bezieht sie aus
den pflichtbeiträgen ihrer 194
mitgliedsländer ca 80 prozent sind
freiwillige beiträge der mitgliedsländer
und spenden von organisationen ein
großteil dieser spenden ist
zweckgebunden
die geber bestimmen was mit dem geld
gemacht wird diese struktur müsse
reformiert werden fordern kritiker sie
ist so lange eingeschränkt wenn ich eine
ordentliche finanzierung gesichert ist
wie das das fordern wir seit vielen
jahren realisiert ist dass wir wirklich
von interessen die von außen ins spiel
gefreut ist ohne höhere pflichtbeiträge
und mehr rechte aber bleibt die whu
abhängig vom willen anderer
ein bisschen sei es wie laufen lernen
sagt italiens ministerpräsident etwa
konnte über den heutigen tag und einen
großen schritt in richtung normalität
nach über zwei monaten betritt die erste
kundin dieses geschäft auf sardinien und
nicht nur der einzelhandel öffnet auch
restaurants und bars dürfen wieder gäste
empfangen ebenso wie museen und friseure
überall gilt abstand halten auch beim
gottesdienst im petersdom den papst
franziskus jetzt wieder mit gläubigen
feierte ob leidenschaftlicher liebhaber
polizist mörder oder papst michel
piccoli hat in seinen über 200 filmen so
ziemlich alles gespielt darunter in
klassikern wie das große fressen oder
der diskrete charme der bourgeoisie ein
großer schauspieler dem es in allen
rollen gelangen auch immer ein wenig
geheimnisvoll zu bleiben
mit 94 jahren ist die ikone des
französischen kinos jetzt gestorben
christoph westerwelle erinnerte er ist
reich und übersättigt das sind seine
beiden hauptsächlichen krankheiten und
die ewige unruhe
darüber hinaus habe ich eine besondere
schwäche für die armen leute die
arbeiten müssen nicht reifer mann mit
seelischen abgründen keiner spielte den
so gut wie piccoli hier in der diskrete
charme der bourgeoisie von 1972 oder
seine sechs filme mit romy schneider
menschen die das glück suchen aber es
kommt eben nicht solche figuren zog
piccoli geradezu magisch an
ich habe immer schwere charaktere
gespielt keine ahnung warum oft hieß es
die rolle geben wir dem piccoli der
schafft er schon eigentlich vom theater
besessen kam der musiker sohn so richtig
erst 1963 im kino an
aber wie die verachtung mit brigitte
bardot und mit der legendären
liebesszene bei der er fast nur zu hören
ist über 200 filme hat piccoli
mitgeschaffen dabei gearbeitet mit
visuell gut da und ja einmal bei topas
auch mit hitchcock
trotzdem blieb er mit seiner art das
fleischgewordene nicht hollywood das
nachdenkliche frankreich sogar ein papst
voller selbstzweifel gab er später in
habemus papam nach all den von ihm
gespielten liebhabern zyniker mit
mördern fast so etwas wie eine komödien
rolle
aber wen wundert's auch die stadt ihm
sehr gut
ein toller mann für die einen ist es
auch morgen wieder sonnig und warm für
die anderen deutlich kühler und trüber
mehr zum gespaltenen better gleich von
katja honnefer das war es von uns danke
für ihr interesse
im heute journal um 21.45 spricht claus
kleber mit afg chef jörg merten und wir
sehen uns hoffentlich morgen wieder
punkt 19 uhr einen schönen abend noch
[Musik]
genau wie meine damen und herren während
sich vom schwarzen meer bis zum atlantik
eine hochdruckbrücke erstreckt ziehen
über nordeuropa und damit auch über
teile von norddeutschland einige tiefen
weg bringen immer wieder dichte wolken
und auch etwas regen
so auch in dieser nacht im süden ist es
dagegen klar und da sinken die
temperaturen auf 9 bis 4 grad unter den
dichteren wolken im norden bleibt es
dagegen milder und morgen dreht sich das
temperaturgefälle um dann ist es an den
küsten von nord- und ostsee am kühlsten
mit 15 bis 16 grad am main am oberrhein
oder auch in der unteren donau werden 25
bis 26 grad erreicht
über norddeutschland sieht morgen eine
kleine kaltfront hinweg bringt
allerdings nur wenig regen mit und am
nachmittag lockern die wolken an der
nordseeküste schon wieder auf viel
sonniger ist es dagegen im südwesten und
am mittwoch fällt noch etwas regen hier
im südosten zu christi himmelfahrt und
am freitag für das hochsommerlich warm
mit wenigen gewitter nach